Alright, you're in trouble Sara. You've gotta, you gotta get the 64 over.
>> Yeah, I'm working on it. I have to get the, the 16 up to 64 status so I can.
>> oh.
>> Oh, I might actually lose this.
>> You're going to lose.
>> Oh, no.
>> Sara, this looks bad. This is looking pretty bad.
>> Wait, before you lose on camera, let's do our introduction.
>> No, look.
>> Okay. Well, I'm going to say hi.
>> Well, slightly better.
>> All right, fine. Hi, I'm Andy.
>> And I'm Sarah.
>> And I'm addicted
to 2048. No, I'm actually an Udacity instructor
>> Who's also addicted to 2048 [LAUGH].
>> Who's also addicted to 2048.
>> Yeah, and I am Sarah. I am
a software engineer and, of course, a developer here.
>> And as I have mentioned, a lot of people at our office
are really addicted to this game and we decided it would be a
good way to start experimenting with
short courses, making really small course that
hopefully, a lot of people will get a lot of enjoyment out of.
>> Yeah. So this course isn't going to teach
you how to play the game. It's not
even going to teach you how to program the game.
Instead, we're, we're going to talk about how to
modify the existing code to make it your own.
>> Right. And I actually went through this experience on my own about a
week ago. I'm a pretty novice programmer.
I've learned what I know through Udacity classes
actually on the job and going through this code base and looking at how
the HTML and the CSS and the
JavaScript interacted. That was a really valuable experience.
So I'm actually really excited to share this with
you guys and make our own versions of 2048.
>> Yeah. So the thing that makes
this project especially useful as a teaching aid
here is that it's an open source project,
meaning that anybody can look at all the
code. They can take it and modify it. They could push their changes back to the
original but most people are just sort of
making their own like fun thing. In fact,
there are a couple of them that have made it pretty big.
>> Should we take a look?
>> Yeah. Let's look at a couple of those.
>> All right.